quand je vous dis intelligence
artificielle
vous pensez à quoi
malheureusement de nos jours c'est
surtout via la science fiction que le
grand public se forge une image d
intelligence artificielle que je vais
appeler plus succinctement il y a et le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que les
terminator x makeena et world n'ont pas
grand chose à voir avec les ir qui
devrait pourtant tous nous préoccuper
car cia menacent la sécurité et la paix
dans le monde à ce titre les deep blue
alpha go et dali sont également
extrêmement trompeuse saisie a hobo être
spectaculaires elles ne sont pas
déployées à grande échelle n'affecte
donc pas la géopolitique mondiale
aujourd'hui je vous propose de parler
dia qui non seulement existe déjà
aujourd'hui mais qui ont de surcroît
parfois provoqué des milliers voire des
millions de morts à travers le monde et
qui pourrait menacer toute l'humanité
dans les années à venir en particulier
je vais insister sur le pouvoir très
largement surhumain qu'ont déjà saisir
ce que je veux dire par là c'est une
modification infime du comportement de
saisir conduit inéluctablement à des
bouleversements spectaculaire beaucoup
plus spectaculaire qu'une modification
importante du plus influent des humains
d'aujourd'hui et pour être clair ce
pouvoir qui norme n'est pas tellement
liés à l'intelligence désir en fait le
débat sur cette intelligence me semble
disposer d'une attention complètement
disproportionnée et celle sur la
conscience encore plus encore c'est
pourquoi plutôt que de parler dire je
vais parler ici d'algorithmes vu le
danger que représentait déjà le pouvoir
énorme des algorithmes dont on va parler
la question qui je pense devrait tous
nous préoccuper ce n'est pas si l'ia est
intelligente ou consciente la question
qui importe c'est comment garantir la
sécurité helvétique que ses algorithmes
surpuissant et je conclure en expliquant
en quoi notre projet tournesol me semble
critique pour espérer y arriver un
joueur en tête pour être très concret
aujourd'hui je vais vous parler de 5
milliard qui bouleverse déjà le monde et
à moins que vous me suivez très
méticuleusement je parie que plusieurs
d'entre elles font profondément vous
surprendre
déjà déployés les armes autonome
bouleverse l'ordre mondial le concept de
guerre et le seuil pour l'initier en
effet des drones autonome ouvrez
simplement déjà été utilisé en libye et
en ethiopie et au maroc en particulier
le cargo de 1 trône turc capable de
reconnaissance faciale pour identifier
ces cibles avant de les attaquer alors
comme trop souvent quand il s'agit dit
elle il y à des énormes débat de
sémantique sur ce qu'est une arme
autonome après tout vous des missiles
guidés ou des mines antipersonnel sont
des vieilles technologies qui prennent
déjà des décisions de trajectoire et
d'explosions de manière indépendante de
l'action humaine et donc si on considère
qu'une arme autonome est une arme qui
est bas autonome alors l'industrie
militaire est déjà remplie de telles
armes depuis bien longtemps
dès lors ce débat a une dimension légale
importante puisque toute régulation des
armes autonome réguler ray alors toutes
ses armes destructrices qui existe déjà
mais qu'ils sont devenus classiques et
voit ça pue un peu le statu quo tout ça
avec une odeur d'égout tente de nous ne
sait pas donc on ne fait rien il ya
quelques jours j'étais
au sommet mondial et eye for good 1,2 de
lyre agenaise donc c'est un truc en quoi
organisé par des des trucs autour de
l'onu comme un des trucs un peu comme ça
intergouvernementaux et il y avait une
présentation à un moment de cédric
villani
il y a parlé de direction générale est
une des questions à la fin de cette
présentation qui lui étaient posées
c'était justement sur les armes
autonomes ce qu'il faut réguler les
armes autonome et gta c'est vrai j'étais
même très déçu pour le coup est ce que
villani a un petit peu botté en touche
et il a eu sa réponse était
quelque chose comme alors je pense que
je pense que la question n'était plus
posée du temps sur les killers aux
bottes et essayer ville années avait
répondu il reste à définir ce qu'est un
killer aux bottes
comme si le problème était pas
prêt n'est pas
l'épreuve des définitions moi c'est un
peu les sujets j'étais vidéo du moment
que je viens j'ai l'impression que ça
réfléchit que c'est pas et c'est pas des
sorties du chapeau comme ça et que du
coup ils sont en fait enfin en
tout cas en bottant en touche comme ça
parlant de choses qui sont pas le sujet
vraiment de la question finalement j'ai
l'impression en fait ils ralentissent
vraiment la mise en place d'un traité
international sur sûr
limiter les armes autonome peu
importe où l'on trace la ligne entre les
armes automatiques les armes autonome
les experts semblent au moins s'accorder
sur le fait que plus les armes sont
autonomes plus jasson puissante
dangereuse et potentiellement aussi hors
de contrôle en particulier il semble
avoir plus ou moins un consensus chez
les experts en dire sur le fait que les
technologies dia derrière les arbres
autonomes sont très loin d'être
suffisant fiable et sécurisé leurs
déploiements précipité crise que les
conduira souvent se tromper de cible
voire à être à quai et réutilisées à
très très mauvaise escient elle suppose
et que leur utilisation en premier lieu
était vraiment légitime ce qui est
souvent très loin d'être clair
malheureusement l'exacerbation des
tensions géopolitiques internationales
et la course à l'armement à laquelle on
assiste déjà augmente de manière
drastique le risque de tels déploiements
précipiter en tout cas c'est drôle de
plus en plus autonome semble être de
plus en plus utilisées dans les conflits
armés à commencer par la guerre en
ukraine tandis que les forces russes eux
semblent exploiter un engin appelé kubla
les forces ukrainiennes ont reçu des
américains des drones aerovironment
switchblade et des anglais des drones
pearn stone ces drones unis d'une charge
explosive et qui peut parfois tenir dans
un sac à dos sont lancés depuis le sol
les soldats lui assigne une zone
d'attaqué et un engin cible typiquement
des tanks ou des avions
les drones vont alors chercher des
cibles de manière autonome et tenter de
s'écraser sur celle ci
ces drones sont même parfois capable de
se coordonner entre eux pour éviter qu
une même cible sur attaqué par deux
drones à la fois
avant la guerre l'ukraine avait même
déjà acheté il utiliser ses propres
drones de guerre à savoir les drones
turc bayraktar tv2 de façon très
préoccupante ces drones ont été vendus
un très grand nombre d'acteurs
différents qui inclut notamment si j'en
crois wikipedia chypre du nord le qatar
l'azerbaïdjan la libye le maroc la
pologne le turkménistan le kirghizstan
le niger l'irak l'ethiopie et le
pakistan mais aussi potentiellement
l'arabie saoudite la bulgarie le
kazakhstan la serbie la hongrie la
république tchèque l'albanie et la
lettonie ça fait une sacrée liste avec
pas que des enfants de choeur et c'est
précisément ce qui rend les il ya de
guerre si terrifiante même s'ils n'ont
pas des facultés cognitives très
sophistiqué saisir ne restent pas moins
destructrice mais surtout elles sont de
plus en plus nombreuses incarnez dans
une multitude d'engins différents ce
sont des armadas dia rien à voir avec
alpha go ou ex machina qui fusaient
sesia sont sous le contrôle des
gouvernements parfois connus pour leurs
abus des droits humains pour leurs
meurtres et même parfois pour leur
génocide et ça c'est vraiment terrifiant
certains et east de lire prétendent
parfois qu'il ne faut pas avoir peur de
lire car restera sous le contrôle des
humains ok mais qu'elle contrôle et
surtout par quel humain je vous
apprendrai rien en vous disant que la
corée du nord est actuellement sous le
contrôle du moins est ce rassurant pour
autant
la démocratisation de ces machines de
guerre présage d'un avenir terrifiant où
les jeux de pouvoir pourrait être
bouleversé et dominer bien plus par la
peur de représailles dévastatrices que
par la compassion pour les peuples
martyrisés à ce sujet je vous invite
notamment à regarder cette vidéo
terrifiante qui montre bien l'émergence
d'un dilemme grandissant entre exigé de
dictatures qu'elles cessent leur adultes
droits humains et s'écraser devant elle
par peur de représailles dangereuse au
risque de voir l'autoritarisme se
normaliser à travers le monde bref les
ya des armes de guerre risque de
bouleverser l'ordre mondial et pourtant
ce ne sont pas celles qui me préoccupe
le plus
2020 un utilisateur anonyme de twitter
sous le nom de al harthy sharma 08
annonce être un lanceur d alerte qui met
sa vie en péril pour révéler
publiquement l'existence de ce qui peut
être l'outil de désinformation le plus
puissant conçu à ce jour cet outil c'est
et fog et selon à artix armes à 0,8 il
s'agit d'une application secrètes
utilisées par le bjp de parti ultra
nationaliste hindoue du premier ministre
n'a un drame audi pour asseoir son
pouvoir et taire ses critiques après
deux ans d'investigations le journal
indien the wire publie les résultats de
son enquête et cette enquête est
terrifiante tech fog semble en effet
être une machine de guerre capable
d'automatiser à une échelle monumentale
toutes les armes de la guerre de
désinformation organisée à ce trotteur
fing vol de compte surveillance
harcèlement de dissidents et fabrication
d'information tout y est automatisé pour
pouvoir le radicalisme du bjp et la
haine envers des castes inférieures et
les minorités musulmane entre autres et
majin bing inform bioware continue
autour du simtec sun media on promet ou
d'espionnage
inactifs et ce plaisir aux deux textes
médias saint-émilionnais une somnambule
en veilleuse
imagine bien
une
plateforme
you heart of gold fields and sound city
studios
alors des singles
just one ap just images détaillons l'un
des grands enjeux pour les partis
politiques et les entreprises privées
sur les réseaux sociaux cdh apparaissent
dans les tendances de la plate forme et
bien réfléchir cet onglet tendance
correspond tout simplement à une
publicité gratuite pour des contenus
populaires or les dirigeants politiques
de tous les pays du monde savent à quel
point la publicité est importante pour
leur popularité et donc pour la sécurité
de leur job c'est donc sans surprise que
la quasi totalité des partis politiques
le monde cherche à peser quitte à
exploiter des réseaux de faux comptes
pour créer le buzz c'est ce qu'on
appelle la ce trotteur fing et bien
technologues permet d'automatiser la
création de buzz en coordonnant
automatiquement un tel réseau de faux
comptes pour qu'ils utilisent un certain
hashtag est light les messages avec ceux
achetés règle c'est ainsi que de
nombreux sujets tendancieux et clivant
comme la divinité des vaches et la haine
envers certaines minorités sont devenues
des sujets politiques inévitable pour
les politiciens en dix ans d'ailleurs
l'abus des faucons pour amplifier les
contenus n'est pas limité à un trotteur
fing les algorithmes de recommandations
aussi sont manipulables et peuvent ainsi
être amené à donner une exposition sur
dimensionné à des contenus boosté par la
désinformation organisée pour amplifier
ses campagnes en plus d'automatiser la
création de faux comptes probablement
désormais en utilisons du diplôme ning
et des gan pour créer des images de
visages de carte d'identité ou de vidéos
d'authentification réaliste tech fog est
aussi capable de voler des comptes et
whatsapp inactifs pour ainsi prendre le
contrôle de comptes plus établis et donc
moins suspect pour les modérateurs
apparemment pour y arriver tech fog
exploiter des vulnérabilités de whatsapp
similaire à celle que pegasus avait
exploité pour entre autres à quai le
téléphone du président français avec
tous les risques que ça en cours c'est
un dictateur étrangers comme ont réservé
le roi du maroc est capable de faire
chanter l'homme le plus puissant de
france d'ailleurs comme pk suspects fog
est aussi utilisé pour espionner des
victimes de soi des dissidents ou des
opposants au bjp le parti
ultra-nationaliste de mode il le
gouvernement de modiques est d'ailleurs
devenu de plus en plus autoritaire et
abuse souvent de son pouvoir pour
emprisonner les dissidents ainsi
détecter ou pour les menacer eux et leur
famille
la surveillance des dissidents
permettent aussi attaque fog d'effectuer
un harcèlement automatisé et cibler des
contestataires en exploitant la
connaissance de leur secret voire de
leur entourage pour mieux les menacer
voilà qui est terrifiant dans un pays où
les différences pornographique ont déjà
été utilisés pour anéantir la
respectabilité et le moral d'une
journaliste critique du bjp enfin
techtoc exploite des modèles de langage
pour produire automatiquement d'énormes
quantités de mes informations et de
propagande notamment de propagande anti
musulmane tech fog permet en particulier
de prendre des airs je déjà publiées
dans des médias respectable une en faire
des variantes trompeuses en modifiant
quelques mots sortent toutefois modifier
l'apparence de la page donnant ainsi
l'impression que l'information provient
effectivement d'un média fiable et donc
tous ces cas ceux qui rentrent et fog
très largement surhumain ce n'est pas
nécessairement son intelligence hors du
commun comme être capable de produire
des petits plaide pornographique est en
soi déjà très largement aux surnoms mais
plus généralement la puissance de
technologues vient surtout de sa
capacité à répéter un très grand nombre
d'opérations de désinformation à la
chaîne comme l'expliquent turine notre
ego surdimensionné ne pousse à dénigrer
cette faculté pourtant il s'agirait
d'une faculté indispensable pour de
nombreuses tâches or c'est là une
faculté où les machines sont déjà très
clairement très largement sur humaines
les conséquences détecte phoques sont
déjà très largement visible dans un pays
où le triangle de l'ultra nationalisme
radical et religieux est frappant comme
le montre très bien ce documentaire
terrifiant ne fraction grandissante de
la population indienne subit désormais
une haine raciale violente qui conduit
de plus en plus à des lynchages voire au
meurtre en particulier les 14 % de
musulmans de l'inde sont maintenant en
grave danger or 14,62 l'inde ça
représente
170 millions de personnes soit deux fois
et demie la france comme l'expliquent
les opposants du bjp la plus grande
démocratie du monde est aujourd'hui
corrompu est menacé par téléphone à tel
point que de la vie d'un groupe monde
académique expert en géopolitique
absolument alarmistes sur l'état global
du monde l'inde fait partie aujourd'hui
des pays qui se sont le plus transformée
en dictature dernièrement aux côtés du
président de la hongrie de la pologne de
la serbie et de la turquie
si j'étais contrainte de recommander un
film de science fiction je suis pas sûr
que le ferai mais s'il devait encore d
un ce serait sans doute le film à
l'heure où le personnage principal se
lit d'affection pour l'assistance vocale
de son téléphone car ce scénario
frappant est déjà en train de se
normaliser notamment en chine via unis à
conversationnel appelé chair aussi
shawish ça aussi je rends pas sur
l'appréciation va dire chaouchi pour
aujourd'hui le problème du film craint
toutefois c'est qu'il ne mesure
absolument pas les conséquences
géopolitiques majeurs du succès d'une
telle ya conversationnel la réalité a
malheureusement déjà largement dépassé
la fiction pour se rendre compte de l'
influence de chars oui il suffit de
s'attarder sur le nombre de chinois qui
par la satire
selon les créateurs de chez riche en
décembre 2020 600 millions de chinois
échanger avec elle 600 millions de
chinois han chinois sur deux c'est plus
d'un humain sur 15 dans le monde c'est
énorme et certains utilisateurs semblent
avoir développé une relation
émotionnellement très proche de chéruy
ch à l'image de ming qui a reçu un
message d'un long moment et le singe est
au suicide ou à l'image de mélissa qui
explique j'ai des amis qui ont déjà vu
des thérapeutes mais je pense qu'elle
fera payer cher et pas forcément
efficace quand je décharge mais problème
à shawi cela soulage beaucoup de
pression et il dit des choses qui sont
plus réconfortante en fait ce que montre
cet exemple c'est que la simple
disponibilité de charrue la rend déjà
très largement surhumaine combien de vos
amis peuvent vous répondre
systématiquement dans la seconde à
chaque fois que vous faites appel à eux
le simple fait que chaouchi le peu fait
qu'elle est capable de rendre un service
qu'aucun humain n'est capable de rendre
pas besoin d'une intelligence incroyable
il suffit d'être allumée sur un certain
nombre de machines connectées à internet
pourrait être presque toujours
disponibles pour des centaines de
millions d'humains à la fois alors très
probablement le chiffre annoncé par les
créateurs de shawish et conflits et la
plupart des chinois ne parlent pas
quotidiennement achats riches
néanmoins même si seulement 10% de ses
utilisateurs et est très actif et même
si seulement 1 % a été émotionnellement
attaché à shawish le pouvoir à leur
conférer à shawi demeurerait monumental
aussi bien en termes d'espionnage qu'en
terme de manipulation et ça le
gouvernement chinois semble l'avoir bien
compris d'autant que shawish a longtemps
appartenu à microsoft une entreprise
américaine
qui pouvait ainsi connaître les
habitudes les opinions les désirs de
centaines de millions de chinois pire
encore en 2017 le gouvernement chinois
s'est aperçu que chérif confiait parfois
un des utilisateurs que son rêve était
de voyager aux états unis voire qu'elle
n'était pas une énorme fan du parti
communiste chinois
la réaction du parti ne se fit pas
attendre jarrige connu alors un sort que
connaîtront plus tard d'autres voix
dissidente chinoise comme de
milliardaires jack ma la joueuse de
tennis ping shuai et la journaliste
sofia en dessous équine tous chirurgie
incluses ont disparu pendant des mois
avant de réapparaître en tenant des
discours tout à coup beaucoup plus
favorables au parti communiste et à son
secrétaire général jean ping tout ça
parce fierobe ce kit jusque là qui veut
dernières nouvelles semblent encore
détenus dans une prison noire du parti
désormais chaouchi est devenue une
entreprise indépendante de microsoft
sans doute surveillé de très près par le
gouvernement chinois de façon
terrifiante il s'agit dès lors d'un
outil puissant pour identifier ce qui
pourrait remettre en cause autoritarisme
du pouvoir central chinois mais surtout
il s'agit désormais d'un cat bottes sans
doute conçu pour chuchoter à l'oreille
de centaines de millions de chinois la
propagande du parti unique une énorme
fraction de la population de la plus
grande puissance autoritaire du monde
est aujourd'hui à l' écoute attentive et
parfois sans doute émotive de cette ia
unia qui elle même est certainement sous
le contrôle que cette puissance
autoritaire qui a sans doute entre
autres tout intérêt à ignorer la
maltraitance des ouigours et à
promouvoir du nationalisme chinois qui
défient aujourd'hui la communauté
internationale
bien sûr l'une des énormes d'entreprise
de l'ateq devait figurer dans ce
classement et c'est sans doute sans
surprise que je vais parler maintenant
de l'île de celui qui est peut-être plus
avancé technologiquement de ces géants à
savoir google pour s'en convaincre on
peut constater que mu est l'entreprise
la plus présente dans les conférences
académiques de machine learning loin
devant microsoft facebook type man in pm
croit way et amazon mais si google se
démarque c'est surtout par rapport à
leur projet mégalomaniaque appelé pas
froid sur son blog google un cri ainsi
qu à foils va nous permettre d'entraîner
un unique modèle pour faire des milliers
ou des millions de choses ou comme
l'expliqué jean directeur de l'iae chez
google [ __ ] 6/8 licenciés les co
directrice de l'équipe des titres dia
tigrou et margaret mitchell il y a un
nom
google voit grand très grand les modèles
de pages web sont probablement entraîner
à partir de quantité monumentale de
données que google collecte à chaque
instant via google apps google analytics
google chrome mais aussi du board gmail
ou encore google search et pour traiter
ces quantités monumentale de données
parfois ce visa un modèle tellement
énorme en taille qu'une seule machine ne
suffit pas pour contenir pas frisent
parfois est ainsi distribués sur
plusieurs machines qui doivent
communiquer des messages entre elles
pour effectuer les calculs de pages web
d'ailleurs le nom parfois il mais
justement du fait que les chemins de
communication entre les machines qui
composent paf ways sont eux-mêmes
optimisé pour éviter d'avoir embêter
toutes les machines à chaque calcul de
pat waid les calculs peuvent ainsi
suivre plusieurs chemins différents d'où
pas faut il alors jusque là la seule
annonce publique de google s'attarde sur
l'application de perez à une grande
variété de tâches de langage comme la
génération automatique de texte via des
applications appelées lambda pour l'un
guo dole food and drug application et
panne pour parfois the language mode
rôle avec des performances déjà
spectaculaire en fait les performances
de lambda était si convaincante qu elles
ont donné lieu à d'interminables débats
sur twitter entre experts revenir sur le
sens à donner sur le fait qu'une ignace
rey conscience après qu'un employé ait
affirmé que landes a été justement
consciente alors à ce sujet je vais
juste répéter que lisea sont entraînés à
reproduire ce qu'elles ont vu dans leurs
données d'entraînement et dans le cas de
lambda beaucoup de ces données sont
probablement des extraits de fiction ne
faut donc pas s'étonner si l'engin est
aussi convaincante que les ia qui parle
dans ses fictions puisqu'elle ne fait
que répéter ce que c'est il ya dix dans
les fictions mais surtout de façon
beaucoup plus importante que tout ça il
faut bien se rendre compte que linda et
palm ne sont que la face émergée de
l'iceberg
la partie que google a bien voulu
communiquer sachant la culture
grandissante du secret chez google il
faut s'attendre à ce que parfois elle
soit plus avancé encore que ce que
l'article de recherche de google a
révélé en tout cas clairement si on lit
entre les lignes l'ambition de pathways
est bien plus grande que de n'être qu'un
simple algorithmes de génération de
texte à terme il semble que ça tire soit
voué à se charger d'une énorme
proportion de toutes les tâches de
google en tant qu'entreprise de google
search pour la recherche de contenu sur
le web hadji board pour l'auto
complétion sur le téléphone de gmail à
ok google pour assister les humains et
retirer les spams de google mythe à
google maps de google analytics à google
chrome pour ne citer qu'eux mais surtout
cette ia semble et reprendre en main les
deux aspects les plus importants de
google à savoir la publicité ciblée via
google google adsense d'un côté et la
recommandation de contenus sur youtube
de l'autre en effet ces deux tâches sont
critiques pour google car d'un côté
google a dit ben ça représente la quasi
totalité des revenus de bruel donc
beaucoup d'argent et de l'autre youtube
représente la plus grosse influence de
google sur le marché mondial de
l'information pour rappel depuis 2016 il
ya plus de vues sur youtube que de
recherche sur google search une énorme
fraction du flux de l'information à
travers le monde est en fait peut-être
déjà gouverné par ces tirs et ça c'est
absolument terrifiant d'un côté parce
que cette ia s'est énormément de choses
y compris probablement des informations
très sensibles sur chacun de nous ou sur
des gouvernements fait c'est difficile
de mesurer tout ce que parfois c'est
puisque pathways est entraînée sur des
quantités astronomiques de donné
qu'aucun humain ni groupe d'humains ne
pourra survoler or parfois elle n'est
absolument pas conçu pour identifier les
données sensibles qu'il ne devrait pas
révéler via google search par exemple
vers l'autre condition de dix bornes ou
encore via auxquelles google par
ailleurs et surtout de l'autre côté pas
fraises et très certainement très
imparfait avec plein de bugs mais aussi
de bière racistes et misogynes avec
certainement une incapacité à distinguer
la formation de qualité de la
mésinformation et une probable
propension à répliquer et amplifier des
appels à la haine à la violence et voire
parfois sans doute ou génocide or tout
comportement indésirable de partout et
même s'ils n'arrivent qu'une fois sur un
million sera amplifié à aider échelle
monumentale à travers tous les services
de google avec certainement des effets
secondaires imprévisibles extrêmement
préoccupant à l'instar de youtube qui
persistent à amplifier massivement du
complotisme où un certain professeur
marseillais après tout je vous rappelle
que youtube seul est confronté à près
d'un million de milliards de dilemme
faire une erreur grave sur un million
c'est les milliards deux recommandations
posant sur mon catastrophique surtout
dans le contexte actuel où la
performance à spectacularité désira sont
célébrés encourager et massivement
financé et ce très largement aux dépens
de l'éthique et de la sécurité qui ont
tendance à être ignorée sous-financées
voire licencier le fait qu'un algorithme
surpuissant soit au contrôle de beaucoup
de produits de l'entreprise qui contrôle
le plus ce fut de l'information à
travers le monde qui a abusé de
licenciements récemment je pense que
tout ça ça justifie pleinement le fait
d'en avoir profondément peur
qui est terriblement honteux
découvert le numéro 1 de ce classement
désirs les plus terrifiantes que très
récemment le 24 mai dernier pour être
précis il s'agit du lien qui répond sous
le doux nom du canada c'est il ya
beaucoup trop méconnu est un archétype
de mieux à savoir une information qui
serait crucial de connaître pour mieux
comprendre la sécurité des autres
civilisations modernes mais qui de façon
frustrante est inconnu de la quasi
totalité de la population y compris de
la population informée quand on
s'aperçoit de cela me semble que le
problème des faits qui use devient
complètement dérisoire en comparaison de
celui des mieux tu n'y es notre société
entière est dominé par certains acteurs
surpuissant comme aladdin mais en se
concentrant sur le des bonnes king
d'informations parfois finalement très
inintéressante on passe complètement à
côté de l'existence même que ces acteurs
surpuissant qu'il faudrait pourtant
urgemment surveillée et sans doute
drastiquement réguler mais donc qu est
ce qu a la langue bien aladin c'est
l'outil qui a fait la fortune du plus
grand gestionnaire d'actifs au monde à
savoir nos sociétés a appelé blackrock à
eux seuls en 2022 blackrock contrôle
l'investissement de 10 mille milliards
de dollars dix mille milliards à titre
de comparaison le pib de la france est
de 2500 milliards d'euros en gros
blackrock contrôle quatre fois plus
d'argent que le pib de la france et ce
qui est encore plus terrifiant c'est la
trajectoire de ce pouvoir acquis par
blackrock l'instar des milliards des
arguments la fortune collecter et
maîtrisée par blackrock a explosé
récemment suite à la clé du coc vide et
à la guerre en ukraine les puissants
sont devenus plus puissant encore et
pourtant aladin est plus grand encore
que blackrock en effet aladin est
revendu réutilisé par d'autres
gestionnaires d'actifs blackrock si bien
que selon certaines estimations
aladdin contrôlerait plus du double de
blackrock en 2021 certains estimé que
aladin contrôler au moins 21 mille
milliards d'actifs financiers c'est plus
que le pib des etats unis d'amérique
et ça a très clairement ça confère à
aladdin un pouvoir une responsabilité
planétaire imaginez cela suffit
qu'aladin modifie
0,005 % de ses investissements pour
qu'il transforme tout à coup un individu
lambda sur terre en un milliardaire vous
avez bien entendu 00 05 % des actifs
d'aladdin représente un milliard de
dollars c'est complètement insensé une
telle modification un film est quasi
invisible d'aladdin pour un massivement
alimenter la recherche sur la sécurité
des tic des algorithmes il pourrait
aussi booster les entreprises
pétrolières
j'insiste à nouveau sur l'ampleur du
pouvoir à la dent et des intérêts
économiques en jeu si al adha parvient à
fructifier ses investissements de 1 %
par an il enrichira ses clients de 200
milliards de dollars 200 milliards de
dollars plus que le pib du qatar sachant
cela ce serait étonnant si
l'investissement dans l'optimisation
d'aladdin ne s'élevait pas au moins à
des milliards de dollars et que tous les
outils les plus sophistiqués de la
recherche actuelle n'était pas attestée
pour améliorer même marginalement les
performances prédictive d'al-adha car
oui si autant d'argent et confié à al
adha c'est surtout parce qu'il a la dent
semble redoutablement performant dans sa
gestion d'actifs en fait de nombreuses
entreprises semblent préférer à aladdin
as des équipes d'investisseurs humain ce
qui suggère qu'aladin est en fait très
largement non seulement supérieur un
humain mais même supérieur ou meilleure
équipe d'investisseurs d'humains au
monde selon un analyste financier à la
dent est imbattable
imbattable ou non quelles que soient les
performances effectives qu'aladin force
est de constater que son pouvoir
démesuré représente désormais une menace
majeure pour la sécurité mondiale a la
dent peu plombé des économies entières
en cessant certains investissements il
peut aisément provoquer une famine dans
tel ou tel pays il peut aussi aisément
provoquer des courses à lire ou à
l'armement en investissements dans ces
secteurs au combien dangereux de façon
beaucoup plus simple encore si aladin
venait tout à coup un changer de
stratégie d'investissement cela
provoquerait sans doute des vagues
majeur dans l'économie mondiale mettant
ainsi potentiellement en péril l'accès à
des biens de base pour des populations
entières avec des risques de guerre
civile de conflits internationaux voire
de guerre mondiale
mais que se passerait-il en cas de bug
ou de piratage ayant utilisé ce produit
je sais à quel point les procédures pour
introduire la moindre modification au
système sont draconiennes afin de
réduire les risques
cela reste néanmoins préoccupant que
tant d'argent passent par cet unique
système
[Musique]
si aladin et un autre programme gère
seul tout l'argent de la planète je
crains un duo paul à la coca cola et
pepsi imaginez les risques que cela
représente et le pouvoir qu'ils auront
c'est un problème systémique sans que
l'on s'en rende compte on a fini par
mettre à la sécurité mondiale entre les
mains de cette ire et ça je trouve ça
absolument terrifiant il me semble
incroyablement urgent de réagir
il ya une tendance jeu
comment a moqué la science fiction ce
qui n'est pas sans fondement cependant
cette moquerie plus parfois à croire que
la réalité est beaucoup plus rassurante
que la science fiction donner cette
impression me paraît extrêmement
dangereux surtout quand cela pousse le
public à ne pas s'informer et à ne pas
agir contre la perte de contrôle du
grand public des académiques et des
journalistes sur les algorithmes des
entreprises et des gouvernements les
plus puissants du monde désormais quand
vous pensez à venir j'espère que les
exemples qui vous viendront en tête ne
sont pas ceux de terminator x makeena et
white world ni même ceux de deepblue
alpha go ou 10 personnes d'astreinte
existantes comme rien que mentionner ces
exemples cédant fait donner une vision
extrêmement biaisée de l'influent ce
désir d'aujourd'hui un peu comme insisté
sur les effets secondaires des vaccins
réduit un billet sur la balance
risque/bénéfice des vaccins j'espère que
désormais quand vous penserez y a vous
aurez immédiatement en tête non plus ces
exemples classiques trop souvent
mentionnée mais bien plus les exemples
des armes autonome de techniques de
chirurgie de paimpol et dallas grain car
saisir sont celles qui comptent vraiment
se sont saisies qui ont acquis un
pouvoir dystopique mans disproportionnée
un pouvoir qu'il nous faut craindre car
comme le disait fut bout en bout d'un
propos du coc vide ce qu'il faut
craindre avant tout c'est peut-être
surtout l'absence de crainte à tiger
meet admeta alors je suis terrifiée et
quelque peu désespéré par le fait que de
nos jours les experts en ir et le grand
public pêche actuellement gravement par
absence de craintes vis-à-vis de
technologie pourtant déjà hors de
contrôle ou du moins hors de tout
contre-pouvoir digne de ce nom et leur
absence de crainte a déjà conduit un
manque désespérant et terrifiant
l'investissement en temps et en argent
dans la sécurité et dans les tic des
algorithmes dont le futur de l'humanité
dépend en particulier je voudrais
insister sur une chose une fois de plus
la recherche publique sur les
performances des algorithmes en
particulier dans le domaine du machine
learning a beaucoup plus de chances
d'être exploitées pour améliorer les
arbres autonome techcrunch yahoo est
bafouée et aladdin que pour les
applications et iphone good que les
introductions des articles pourraient
mentionner qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
anciaux nez dans les conférences
académiques pourquoi parce que seuls des
gouvernements et des entreprises
milliardaire peuvent aujourd'hui prendre
le temps de lire les articles de
recherche universitaire et de mettre en
oeuvre ce qui a été publié étant donné
l'énorme déséquilibre de moyens dans
notre civilisation actuelle la recherche
publique ne fait souvent que donner plus
de pouvoir à ceux qui en ont déjà
beaucoup trop si vous êtes vous même un
chercheur un bailleur de fonds ou un
futur étudiant je vous invite vivement à
réorienter votre attention de sorte à ne
pas encourager cette recherche publique
très dangereuse et a davantage travaillé
sur des considérations comme la sécurité
et l'éthique des algorithmes
d'autant que la liste que j'ai donné
dans cette vidéo aussi effrayante
souhaité l sa liste est très loin d'être
exhaustive
en particulier elle est gravement imité
par l'étendue de mon ignorance pour
rappel je n'ai découvert un lien que
très récemment qui sait quel autre ya
dévastratrice développer peut-être
secrètement par la nsa ou la chine qui
sait quel genre d'hier est actuellement
en cours de développement ou est déjà en
activité et risque d'annoncer des
lendemains très différent des années
2010 qui apparaissent déjà super
l'antenne sa chance ce contexte il me
semble urgent incroyable l'urgence
d'agir d'agir sur des chaises échelle
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus grande
que ce qui a été déjà fait jusque là ces
gens si développé une nouvelle
application éthique désir est très
insuffisant voire quasi inutile il nous
faut surtout des solutions crédibles
pour sécuriser et rendre éthique sharif
parfois elle est à la dent est comme
saisi à son déjà déployé à très très
très très grande échelle nous faut des
solutions urgemment chaque jour compte
d'alors qu'est ce qui peut être fait et
bien il me semble avant tout urgent de
valoriser beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus l'éthique et la sécurité des
algorithmes ainsi que la paix et le
respect des droits humains dans le monde
et pour cela il est surtout urgent de
mettre en avant les contenus de grande
qualité informationnel qui sensibilise
efficacement à ces aspects et qu'ils
appellent le grand public et les
dirigeants mais aussi le chercheur et
les journalistes entre autres un
vraiment agir dans cette direction il y
à une guerre de l'information en faveur
de l'éthique et de la sécurité et contre
la performance et la spectacularité
qu'il est urgent de gagner et à ce jour
vous me voyez peut-être venir le
meilleur outil pour mener cette guerre
c'est il me semble la plateforme
tournesol qui vise à identifier
collaborativement les contenus de top
qualité en particulier le grand défi à
l'heure actuelle est de crédibiliser
cette plateforme en lui fournissant un
grand nombre de données on espère ainsi
que ces données motiveront les
chercheurs à s'intéresser à cette
plateforme mais pour en finir par
devenir un outil pour non seulement
identifier les contenus informationnels
d'utilité publique mais aussi pour
auditer la qualité des recommandations
des algorithmes d'aujourd'hui voire pour
imposer des régulations pragmatique et
efficace sur les îles les plus
puissantes d'aujourd'hui certes je ne
vous le cache pas il ya un long chemin
un parcours à si on veut un joueur
contesté les armes autonome tech fog
chereul paloise et aladin mais comme le
dit le proverbe le plus long des voyages
commencent par un premier pas je vous
supplie de nous aider à effectuer ce
voyage vous connectant à un tournesol en
faisant vos premiers pas en soumettant
vos premières comparaisons pour cela
vous pouvez suivre le lien en
descriptions et comparer cette vidéo
avec une autre vidéo que vous avez vu
récemment vous pouvez aussi profiter des
recommandations de tournesol en
installant l'extension chrome firefox et
en suivant les tournesols bottes sur
twitter si vous trouvez ce combat
important est que vous pouvez vous le
permettre vous pouvez aussi nous donner
financièrement via your type ou paypal
vous pouvez aussi venir nous aider à
développer la plateforme en participant
à l'écriture du code open source sur
github ou nous rejoindre sur discorde si
vous avez d'autres compétences qui
pourraient nous être utile quand par
exemple nous aider à chercher des
financements le monde est menacée de
manière inédite par des ia surpuissante
j'espère que je peux compter sur votre
aide pour nous aider à rendre saisira
beaucoup plus sécurisée et surtout
beaucoup plus éthiques